this next question comes from christoph
benos
is there anything legitimate regarding
ufos any credible source
any links to anything tangible no of
course christos it depends on what one
means by ufo because plenty is
classified as as such
i understand what you mean though and i
would say that there's
no
at least none not that's accessible to
the public there's nothing that is not
circumstantial evidence that the public
has access to to suggest that the
causal factors what's behind the ufos is
it's it's entities it's precipitated by
something that far
escapes our current understanding or our
phylogenetic tree it's either not a part
of it or it's from some aspect of it
that we don't currently understand or
have
a conception of the
circumstantial evidence that does exist
is plenty and i would say that it's more
so than
either amber heard or johnny depp had
against one another combined yet the
whole world seemed to have placed
themselves pertinaciously on one side of
the spectrum or one side of the aisle
there the world is a
at least
well the more one investigates it the
world is a place of
of paradoxical complexity
and the familiar is an aberration
and so i don't hold the view that
ill-defined and esoteric topics
should be
viewed upon or explored
with
scorn or derision
and
it took me
years and years and years to realize
that my criticism that i felt like was
dispassionate and purely from a rational
perspective was from a place of of
arrogance i thought it came from a place
of reasoning
building up from quote-unquote first
principles i believe myself to be
operating from such a place but i'm
deeply skeptical of people who
haven't realized that about themselves i
know from personal experience how
delusive it can be to think that one is
operating from a position of a rational
standpoint when
virtually all the evidence that we have
is that
all the psychological evidence we have
is that that's decidedly not the case
we're far more we care far more about
our position on a social echelon than we
do about almost anything else
and so
well
that was a tangent and i appreciate the
question christos
ali says what would be the
what would be your thoughts on
metaphysics in the means of chaos and
accidents oriented essence of reality we
face now
and how would you eliminate absurdities
of living and truth if we take them as
the case take nietzsche take nietzsche
as your rival i'm sorry ali i don't
understand the question avesta says hey
dude have you heard of the e8 model so
yes that's someone from someone named
garrett lisa's model and at some point
this year hopefully i will be speaking
to him perhaps around the same time i
get
the chance to take a look at geometric
unity julian weinstein weinstein
says to know that consciousness is
fundamental must want to experience this
directly is there any way to
through words or logic realize that
space time is not fundamental in other
and by the way about the
space time not being fundamental much a
do is made about that and either
excoriate excoriating or venerating
donald hoffman but the majority of
physicists don't believe space time to
be fundamental and it's also not that
outlandish to think so
okay lastly
what is required to grok this as an
altered state neural psychologically
neurophysiologically via psychoactive
substances and what does that say about
the causal power of the brain if
anything so i don't i don't know julian
i don't know the answer to your question
all i know is that the last sentence the
causal power of the brain has embedded
in it an assumption of what one is
is
is trying to prove or derive from that
point so that is assuming that the brain
is and is mind independent in some
manner than concluding mind independence
and all of this is a
place that all of this is a
decidedly difficult
treacherous domain because are
enthymemes everywhere enthymemes being
these unstated assumptions that are so
embedded and subtle we don't realize
them that we've made them until years or
decades millennia later i believe many
many many of our philosophical problems
perhaps all of them are like that
jojo752 says kurt i've been following
you for a while now and i'm glad you've
gained such a following congrats hey
thank you joe
my question is
as someone that generally listens to the
podcast not youtube is there any
chance you could have an email that
accompanies your interviews with slides
there's a collective attempt right now
on the discord so i'll place a link to
the discord somewhere
where people are making notes show notes
for every episode meticulous
meticulously i meticulously timestamp
they meticulously summate particularly
this person named or this user named
timecake i'll leave a link to all of
that in the description curbkila says
what would you ask uh extra
extraterrestrial being as a first
question
if you were the first to get an
interview
i don't know if i had one question
that's a bit too much pressure curb
killers i need to think about that some
more